ront off for doson doson snaps it down
for Horvat marzel popped out and then
Lee's turnaround shot kicked Away by
kakin ranov picks it up Orvac moves
it along and then a quick pass from goer over
for Holstrom Holstrom into the slot goer shoots
scores Julian goer Gos in back the back games
I'll tell you what that was a great offensive
individual play by by Holst was able to get that
puck all the way across and watch him hang on to
it cut back to the middle a perfect pass quick
wrist shot no doubt about that one go taking the
making excuse me the most of his opportunity could
to be a hard guy to get out of the lineup now BR
certainly is we figured he'd be a good fit there
with a fight as well if need be here's a chance
for Ang ball in alone and he's denied by the
coule of the glove of coochin the Islanders won
Back toback Games 51 and one in their last seven
here's Anthony duclair driving wide on Riley off
the side of the net and came to the slot Mayfield
guided it away but right out in front for hurdle
and he scores Tomas hurdle picks a corner and
ties the score boy you couldn't ask for a better
opportunity could you and and the wrong guy that's
for sure LS the play by declair tries to good move
there and then number two buuk just leaving the
the front of the net and man alive that's just too
good an opportunity Corvette sort of has it and
there a play off there he can't lead the front of
the net boy oh boy that's just RI excuse me that's
my not buluk but Riley Riley here's Riley with Lee
ahead of the pack he'll give it to barzel Horvat
charging along with him barzel has Riley leaves
it for him Mike Riley circling the net all the
way around got some space force kinin to make a
save shark's penalty kill is 31st in the National
Hockey League but looking awfully solid in their
first test today looking like number one right
now but most of the problems have have not come
from good penalty killing it's been all about the
Islanders inability here is Nelson he scores and
it's a power play goal oh yeah baby safe play for
the sharks nice plays skating across little pass
and watch Brock head towards the Ed he such
a good wrist shot that was effortlessly but
look at this shot here where does he going with
oh right off the post right up over the blocker
terrific play you know what I love there but
you've got an opportunity to one time it yeah
if you don't a lot of guys stay stationary right
there returns it to Romanov Nelson comes to the
wall middle of the ice Romanov shot blocker save
rebound for Ang ball shut down to the post by
cochan Ang will had a turn around for this punck
Thompson to romano and then Paul Mary angles it
on touch to head here's a breakway EG B save
made by kinen power play here for the Sharks
and they pushed it wide second power play of
the game and it's a short-handed opportunity
Paso and hom stroke P stopped by kinen that's
a third break away he stopped 13 seconds left
on the C is penalty Holstrom he's got
the gas in the tank trying to get there
Paso along with him Holstrom back to check
Away by gramlin yeah just what a feed Riley
scores a short-handed goal for Mike Riley again
good hard work by Pou and here's the two-on-one
opportunity but good job on the braack check
knocks it into the corner but homom stays with
it spots Riley coming in where did he shoot
it Brendon where did he shoot it right up over
the glove we've been talking about it tremendous
play by homest he loves to kill penalties doesn't
he he certainly does and for a guy who had zero
assists oh big believe it or not the first time
the Islanders have had a fiveon three power
play this season here's barzel Puck on edge
settles it drags it plays it Nelson oh what a
save from kupo cocking it any other chance to
make the save so still a power play for 47 more
seconds with hurdle in the Box for tripping second
unit out for the Isler Power Play Broken stick
for the shark they score Ryan pulock a 97 mph
heater opportunity because he one defenseman
oh ohuk loses his stick so now he's got to
get one there's it no that's plas excuse me and
look at that shot just a rifle of a shot that's
great recognition by Mike Riley you pointed out
the broken stick P all of a sudden I believe it
was Bailey went back in to hand a stick and
with that could should a low if it's 97 yeah
when it can go through him it doesn't matter oh
turn over in front Clutterbuck can't get it to
Zas sets up a chance for fashing diers goal
Ryan poock is second from Riley and pageo on
power play interesting score line just because
for Mike Riley it's his 100th NHL point for JG
Paso it's his 300th as that shot got through Kido
huk Let It Go from the wall and with traffic in
front of sokan and gets by him and it's 4-2
looks like leok maybe deflected one that one
in front chip play watch he's going to try and
make a little chip play out there not able to
handle as barzel and deflected by number 62 out a
little bit further to stick on it both defensemen
up I don't think sokin saw that one at all R but
a good good deflection play Ferraro touched along
for hurdle to hurdle aranov out for rud or vasic
his shot hit the post given out for ooak his shot
knocked down on it way to the net barzel has
Horvat behind the defense couldn't find a way
to get it through he'll take Lee with him over
the line Lee barzel with the tip and another fine
save by cocko coochin it and you know what it's
the right move I mean you're down two so you I
mean you got to figure out a way to score two
goals in three minutes here's Eckland down to
the goal line zerin Eckland shot by granin change
directions it's loose and they score toos hurdle
has made it a one-goal game second tonight four
hurdle and the sharks are not going away quietly
just see what happens as Mayfield's in the in
the at the front of the N wow that's a lot of
bounces for a goenda go out one two right to the
back door hurdle with a nice finish you mentioned
him Butch he's he good players the puck seems
to find them but you got to be able to do the
rest nice and Shifty little zerin across the
ice duclair barabanov to the net and a save
by sokin May field an opportunity to get it
out does not zerland gloved it down kept it
alive barabanov for ekin along back door they've
tied it with a hattick goal from Tomas hurdle
unbelievable now the Islanders have the chance
Mayfield has it tries not to ice the puck and
then the Islanders all get up ice Romanov I mean
no chance there I mean you and again the Puck's
in front of the goenda Brendon so leave the puck
in front of the goal tender Islanders still found
a way to get it to Nelson Islanders will get
some fresh forwards out of the ice as barzel
pops out while Ryan pulock steps in pulock for
barzel morvat now on the ice one timer off the
bar it nice saveing off the off the post there
on a as he got tangled up there with Ferraro
Puck was available Ecklund got to it first
he sends it ahead now the Sharks hurrying up
ice Eckland two-on one with Ferraro William eckan
saok it Thompson wrestling with grin for the puck
centering feet only was there 12 seconds to go in
OT a shootout to follow here's grantlin with six
leaves it for eckan and he scores William eckan
completes the overtime comeback for the San Jose
Sharks they're they're back but again
nobody's taking anybody barcel tries to
get to get over there just a just a great
shot that gets past so Ren just Dr so